Speaker 1: On the Friday show, I am going
to be answering an audience question about
which Republicans are likely to get out of
the way if Donald Trump runs in 2024 versus
which Republicans are likely to run against
Trump in twenty twenty four.
The list of the latter is probably relatively
short.
I think Mitt Romney would be someone who is
on the list, even though I don't think Romney
plans to run.
Romney is the type of guy who, if he wants
to run in twenty twenty four, he'll run against
Trump in the Republican primary.
He won't step down or step back or stand by
because Donald Trump may choose to run.
The new report from Axios is that Chris Christie's
friends believe he is gearing up for a 2024
run axios writing that former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie is seriously considering running
for president in 2020.
For three people familiar with his thinking,
tell Axios, while Christie isn't saying anything
publicly besides telling radio host Hugh Hewitt
that he's not ruling it out, people close
to Christie have a sense of the rationale
and outlines of a candidacy.
The big picture is that absent a run by Trump,
the field would be wide open.
Christie ran in 2016, didn't go well.
He told friends he'd be the only person in
2024 with executive experience who's run a
presidential race before.
I guess that's maybe true when you compare
him to like Ted Cruz.
Ted Cruz has run, but he doesn't have executive
experience.
I guess that sort of makes sense.
But Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has executive
experience for whatever reason.
Governorships are called executive experience.
I guess that's because there are more administrative
in a sense than, for example, being a member
of the House or a member of the U.S. Senate.
DeSantis, as Axios writes, is experiencing
a surge of popularity from Republicans because
he opened Florida wide open very early.
But DeSantis has not yet been scrutinized
by national media as a candidate and who knows
what might surface from that.
Axios writes that Christie's approach would
be to run on his reputation for being tough
and that that could appeal to the Trump base.
But he's not going to come off as reckless
the way Donald Trump came off, you know, the
entire George Washington Bridge closing down
a lane as a political punishment.
That seems pretty reckless to me.
But I guess when you're comparing the recklessness
of Christie to the recklessness of Trump,
he seems less.
That's true, Axia Axios also writes that Chris
Christie may have crossover appeal to blue
collar voters as well as suburban center right
voters, that's possible and also that his
experience as a former federal prosecutor
could distinguish him in debates and prepare
him for a primary where there may be more
of a premium placed on sort of being buttoned
up rather than being unhinged like Donald
Trump.
I think that this is tough for Chris Christie.
You know, the things that he's known for really
in my mind are the Bridgegate fiasco and supporting
Donald Trump in completely humiliating fashion
in 2016.
And neither of those are particularly inspiring
from my perspective.
But listen, maybe the Republican primary voters
would would like it.
Christie didn't do well in 2016.
I don't know that he ever had more than like
two or three percent support.
But listen, things are different.
And I think what is abundantly clear is that
Christie is only a candidate if Trump does
not run and again, will dig into that in more
detail on Friday, who might actually run against
Trump?
Because Christie is only a candidate.
If Trump is not, Ted Cruz isn't going to run
against Donald Trump.
Lindsey Graham, forget about it.
Lindsey Graham, I don't think is running regardless.
But Lindsey Graham is not going to run against
Donald Trump.
Nikki Haley told us last week or was it Monday
that she if Donald Trump runs, she won't run
and she will support Donald Trump so that
that is the situation with Chris Christie.
I actually what's crazy is.
If you said to me, whoever wins the Republican
primary will be the president.
Chris Christie is maybe the guy I lean towards.
I mean, if you say Chris Christie or Ted Cruz
will be the next president, I'm going with
Chris Christie.
If you say Chris Christie or I don't even
know, you know, Rand Paul will be the next
president.
I'm going with Chris Christie.
He has I'm not praising him, but he has more
centrist sensibilities.
He actually seems competent in a narrow way
that Donald Trump is not.
When you think about his experience as a prosecutor
and as a governor, he did horrible things
as a governor.
Bridgegate is an immoral fiasco.
But I probably lean towards someone like Chris
Christie more than just about anybody I can
think of that ran in.
I mean, Kazik.
And again, I'm not saying these people are
my ideal candidates.
It's just if I knew that the Republican nominee
would be the president, I'm leaning towards
someone like maybe Kasich or Chris Christie,
despite having many, many disagreements with
them.
So let me know what you think about Chris
Christie's potential candidacy.
We'll talk Friday about who might actually
fight Trump in the 2024 Republican primary
if it were to come to that.